a
la religión y la política van siempre de
la mano en la península árabiga la cuna
del islam
[Música]
cada año más de 2 millones de peregrinos
musulmanes viajan a arabia saudita para
visitar la meca en abu dhabi convive la
arquitectura más moderna del planeta con
el apego por tradiciones milenarias
en esta zona del mundo el islam es la
ley y sin embargo si te dijera que esta
zona del mundo y es el lugar de mayor
crecimiento del cristianismo
ah
sí sí mientras europa parece darle la
espalda a la iglesia católica es justo
aquí en el epicentro del mundo islámico
donde más está creciendo la población
católica al salam al aire capaces y agua
cómo es esto posible que ha pasado en
abu dhabi para que incluso el papá
francisco les haya hecho una visita
estamos ante un cambio histórico o tal
vez no
en este vídeo te lo vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el papá francisco es algo así como el
leo messi- de la religión da igual si
eres o no católico o si eres o no eres
del barça porque hagan lo que hagan o
digan lo que digan todo el mundo va a
estar atento a sus movimientos además
tanto messi como el papá francisco
tienen seguidores en los lugares más
insospechados
[Música]
porque seamos honestos tanto en europa
como en latinoamérica la iglesia
católica no pasa precisamente por su
mejor momento ya que no sabéis dónde si
están creciendo en creyentes exacto en
la península árabiga países como arabia
saudita qatar o emiratos árabes unidos-
tienen cada vez más y más católicos y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando pero como es
esto posible
por supuesto que tanto en qatar como en
emiratos árabes unidos- es posible
construir iglesias pero echadle un
vistazo a la catedral de abu dhabi
[Música]
y no parece un templo católico lo cierto
es que es ilegal que se muestren cruces
en este país está terminantemente
prohibido predicar cualquier religión
que no sea el islam y lo mismo pasa si
eres musulmán y te conviertes a otra fe
es un delito así que como os podéis
imaginar este crecimiento de la fe
católica en la península arábiga se debe
a una única palabra inmigración si
seguís visual política desde hace tiempo
ya sabéis que en esta zona del mundo hay
más inmigrantes que población local en
qatar o en emiratos árabes unidos-
hablamos de más del 80 por ciento de la
población por supuesto que muchos de
estos inmigrantes son musulmanes gente
que viene de países como bangladesh o
pakistán pero también hay
estadounidenses colombianos o filipinos
que resulta que son católicos y eso
explica cosas como esta
ah
visita papal el papá francisco aterriza
en abu dhabi para su histórico primer
viaje al golfo habéis oído bien por
primera vez en la historia el papá de la
iglesia católica ha visitado la
península arábiga y su viaje ha sido
como una jmj en miniatura 180 mil
personas acudieron a su misa en abu
dhabi más del doble de asistentes que la
última misa que dio en un país tan
católico como chivas
[Música]
en otras palabras sm danny traduce tu
canal al árabe que ahí tienes mercado y
os preguntaréis pero porque han
permitido este éxito católico en un país
musulmán es más porque ha ido el papá
abu dhabi que puede conseguir hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
non verba el papá francisco y messi
tienen muchas cosas en común ambos son
capitanes de sus organizaciones aunque
en realidad francisco es el líder de
tres organizaciones a la vez habéis oído
bien
[Música]
por un lado el papá es la cabeza de la
jerarquía eclesiástica esa es su parte
religiosa donde no vamos a entrar porque
esto es un canal de política y no de
religión pero lo cierto es que su
santidad el papá también tiene un rol
político por un lado es el jefe de
estado de una nación soberana la ciudad
del vaticano si es el estado más pequeño
del mundo pero es un estado y además
también es el jefe de la santa sede- y
creedme ciudad del vaticano puede ser el
país más pequeño del mundo pero la
influencia que tiene la santa sede- a
nivel diplomático es simplificar
[Música]
tienen embajadas en prácticamente todos
los países del mundo y han jugado un rol
fundamental en la historia por ejemplo
el papa juan pablo segundo fue una pieza
fundamental para la caída del comunismo
tanto en polonia como en toda la unión
soviética y fue una de las principales
voces en contra de la guerra de irak su
sucesor benedicto 16 fue algo menos
político su legado se mide más por sus
ensayos y sus encíclicas que por su
trabajo diplomático
pero el actual pontífice es todo lo
contrario tal vez uno de los papás más
políticos de todos los tiempos y por eso
es por lo que genera tantas opiniones
contradictorias para unos es un malvado
comunista y para otros el gran renovador
y adalid de la justicia social un hombre
al que no le tiembla el pulso para decir
estas cosas del capitalismo
[Música]
y el papá francisco sobre la desigualdad
económica una economía así mata desde
luego jesucristo podría hablar en
parábolas pero al papá francisco no le
gusta eso de andarse con rodeos
y el papá donald trump no es cristiano
si quiere construir un muro fronterizo
sin embargo si nos vamos a los hechos
descubrimos un papá muy pero que muy
distinto sí y donald trump decía eso de
los americanos primero la política de
francisco podría resumirse también como
los católicos primero
y así que esto puede sonar un poco
prosaico pero vamos a ver la iglesia
como si fuera una multinacional bajo
este prisma el catolicismo está cayendo
en sus mercados tradicionales el número
de creyentes en europa se está
derrumbando año tras año y en américa
latina afronta una feroz competencia con
las iglesias evangélicas así que en el
vaticano lo han tenido claro hay que
buscar nuevos mercados los que seguís
visual polític desde hace tiempo
posiblemente recordaréis el vídeo que
dedicamos a ese acercamiento de la
iglesia católica con el régimen
comunista de china si no lo habéis visto
le podéis encontrar aquí os hago un
resumen rápido por si no habéis visto el
vídeo el catolicismo estaba prohibido en
china y como los chinos son muy listos
se habían inventado una iglesia católica
made in china que era muy parecida a la
del vaticano pero donde los obispos los
nombraba el partido comunista los
católicos que se mantenían fieles al
papa de roma eran enviados a campos de
concentración donde se les torturaba y
se les sacaban los órganos para los
trasplantes
ante esta situación probablemente juan
pablo segundo habría optado por un
perfil más combativo pero francisco es
mejor negociante que el propio donald
trump y ahí es donde entra el sistema de
trasplantes de órganos chino durante
años china ha estado extirpando órganos
de presos políticos para su sistema de
donantes hay toda clase de presiones
internacionales para que china acabe con
este sistema que viola los derechos
humanos y desde beijing mientras tanto
lo niegan todo aunque todas las pruebas
afirman lo contrario pues bien el
vaticano fue el primer y único estado
del mundo hasta la fecha que invitó a
los diplomáticos chinos para que
pudieran vender las bondades de ese
sistema de trasplantes que por supuesto
no viola los derechos humanos hombre por
favor pero como si os ha ocurrido pensar
que nosotros los chinos en algún momento
podríamos violar los derechos humanos
con lo amantes que somos de la paz la
tolerancia y la democracia en otras
palabras que el papá francisco dio carta
de naturaleza a los trasplantes de
órganos chinos y que consiguió con
semejante estrategia jueces
[Música]
soy china y el vaticano llegan a un
acuerdo sobre el nombramiento de los
obispos fácil sencillo y para toda la
familia bastó con una negociación
diplomática y boom la iglesia católica
acaba de sumar 12 millones de feligreses
nuevos sólo con esto ya han compensado
la pérdida de creyentes en españa
durante los últimos 30 años así que cuál
ha sido la siguiente parada del
papamóvil exacto el mundo árabe mientras
benedicto 16 criticaba abiertamente el
islam francisco ha dado un giro de 180
grados en este tema por ejemplo os
acordáis de los atentados de charlie
hebdo casi todos los líderes mundiales
condenaron los ataques y el terrorismo
religioso sin embargo en este caso el
papá francisco sí que ha optado por las
parábolas y los rodeos
no se puede insultar la fe de los demás
si el doctor gasbarri dice una mala
palabra en contra de mi mamá puede
esperarse un puñetazo es normal pero los
gestos de amor hacia el islam no se
quedan aquí por ejemplo aquí tenéis
otros
en esta foto tenemos al papá francisco y
al gran imán de al-azhar máximo
representante de los musulmanes sunníes
juntos haciendo un llamamiento para
construir un mundo más tolerante y menos
violento y os preguntaréis para qué
sirve este acercamiento usa ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
y esclavistas pero tolerantes otra cosa
que tienen en común messi y el papá
francisco es su familia como buenos
argentinos ambos son descendientes de
inmigrantes italianos y donde también
hay muchos inmigrantes es en la
península arábiga
pero bueno como en todo siempre hay
clases y hay que distinguir entre dos
tipos de inmigrantes los expats y los
inmigrantes normales el ex pad es un
europeo o estadounidense que se va a
trabajar un par de años a exxon mobile
cobrando una auténtica pasta
[Música]
el inmigrante es el asiático que
comparte habitación con otros diez
trabajadores trabaja 12 horas al día y
cobra un salario ridículo la mayor parte
de estos inmigrantes trabaja en la
construcción o como empleada del hogar y
con esos sueldos miserables mantienen a
sus familias que viven a miles de
kilómetros de distancia y diréis bueno
si no les gustan las condiciones
laborales siempre pueden volver su país
verdad hoy aquí todos a quejarse
pues veréis no es tan fácil en arabia
impera el llamado sistema catalán según
la caf a la los inmigrantes están
ligados a un local que es su
patrocinador eso significa que si
quieren cambiar de trabajo de empresa o
marcharse del país necesitan el permiso
de este patrocinador si el patrocinador
no les da el permiso están condenados a
seguir trabajando durante años en
condición de esclavitud pues bien sólo
en emiratos árabes unidos hay más de un
millón de católicos que viven bajo este
sistema
e inmigrantes que vienen de filipinas o
de algunas partes de la india y como os
podéis imaginar en semejante situación
uno se aferra a la religión más que otra
cosa por otra parte aunque estén en
condición de esclavitud todos estos
trabajadores son fundamentales para la
economía árabe en otras palabras que
construir una catedral en abu dhabi es
la forma más barata de tener
moderadamente contentos a los que
sustentan tu economía
y os preguntaréis pero cómo es posible
que en un sitio donde está prohibido
hacer proselitismo de otras religiones
se pueda construir una catedral pues mis
queridos amigos de visual político el
enemigo de las monarquías árabes no son
ni los cristianos ni los hindúes son
otros musulmanes
por ejemplo los hermanos musulmanes
pensadlo bien y es más peligroso para
los jeques los inmigrantes filipinas
rezando en una iglesia o los hermanos
musulmanes que no aceptan otra autoridad
que el corán creo que está claro no por
eso en emiratos árabes unidos- tienen
mejores cosas que hacer que dedicarse a
perseguir cristianos y eso explica
tantísima tolerancia a cambio de poder
violar los derechos humanos
sistemáticamente
gracias
papá en abu dhabi y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando vale puede que en abu
dhabi permitan que se construye una
iglesia pero y una vista del papa para
que era necesario traer al representante
de otra religión al país pues lo cierto
es que les viene genial por un lado
mejoran su imagen al exterior de repente
este país que era famoso por el
fanatismo islámico ahora acoge al líder
de otra religión a ver quién es el guapo
que se atreve a poner en duda la
modernización en el mundo árabe pero no
sólo eso con apenas esfuerzo
abu dabi le acaba de dar una alegría
enorme a su población católica esta
visita son buenas noticias tanto para
esos filipinos que trabajan por cuatro
petrodólares como para los europeos que
están con mega soldados en las
multinacionales
[Música]
pero la pregunta la auténtica pregunta
es que hagan entonces la iglesia
católica pues pensarlo bien el papá ha
llegado a una zona del planeta donde
estaba prohibida la evangelización y ha
conseguido que le dejen organizar la
madre de todas las misas
hablamos de una misa en el principal
estadio de fútbol del país con 180.000
personas y esta pedazo de cruz que se
podía ver hasta desde el último minarete
de abordar a esto se le llama poner una
pica en flandes y todo esto explica que
el vicario apostólico de arabia el
kinder diga estas cosas tan bonitas del
gobierno de los emiratos árabes
[Música]
rezad por los gobernantes de este país
que hacen posible la visita agradezco al
gobierno de los emiratos árabes unidos
por su generosidad no sólo han hecho
posible la visita sino que nos han
brindado de todo corazón un lugar para
celebrar la misa y que me decís del papá
francisco con donald trump no tiene
pelos en la lengua ahora bien durante
toda su visita no ha dicho ni una
palabra ni del sistema kafala ni
muchísimo menos de la guerra de yemen
nuestro país tierra que secuestra un
país tierra que quiere ser un modelo de
convivencia de fraternidad humana y de
encuentro entre diferentes
civilizaciones y culturas rica en
cultura después de todos estos gestos no
sería raro si emiratos árabes unidos
terminará quitando las restricciones
religiosas al menos las que afectan al
catolicismo
podría un espaldarazo tremendo para la
iglesia católica en un mercado aún por
explotar así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que el papá es un
genio de la negociación tal vez debería
preocuparse un poco por los derechos
humanos podríamos decir que se merece el
'balón de oro' a la diplomacia a fin de
cuentas es cristiano y siempre viste de
blanco podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y si queréis ampliar
nuestra perspectiva os dejo este otro
vídeo respuesta que ha hecho sm danny en
su canal hablando sobre el mismo tema
que se me dan y es el sacerdote más
famoso de todo youtube y tiene
perspectivas y entrevistas muy
interesantes aquí podréis ver una visión
de la política papal desde el punto de
vista de un creyente que las cosas como
son conoce la iglesia como la palma de
su mano
y por supuesto no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual polític y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones que os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]